Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
bring on the holiday cheer.
‐Hi, Santa!
I'm about to let you in
on one of the North Pole's
best kept secrets.
You don't even need ice.
Corcoran: There you go.
Do a spin.
Narrator:
But not too much cheer.
‐What are your sales?
‐$15,000.
Your building is on fire.
‐Hello.
‐Oh!
‐Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Last year,
we sold 350,000.
‐What does it cost me?
‐15 grand, give or take.
I need Mark Cuban
on the phone with me.
‐Everybody needs a Mark Cuban.
‐I want 50%.
It's a ‐‐ It's a little
steep, Kevin.
‐It's downright greedy.
‐That's the only deal.
And if you don't want it,
I'm okay.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Total sales, $1.3 million.
‐That's really interesting.
‐You are one ripped dude.
What's the difference between
your product and the other one?
That is proprietary.
We shouldn't have
to pull teeth.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
The offer's so good
you're crying?
♪♪
My name is Sarah Blain,
and I live with my two beautiful
daughters, Sienna and Milan.
Christmas is my favorite
time of year.
‐Up high!
‐Up high?
Sarah: The girls and I love
decorating the tree,
making Christmas cookies,
wrapping presents.
Good job!
The kids just love everything
to do with Christmas,
so we just kind of overdo it.
Did you get
Rudolph's footprint?
It's no surprise
that I have a business
that revolves around
my favorite holiday.
When doing research,
I found something online
that was similar to what
I wanted to do,
and I knew I could do it better.
Parents love this product ‐‐
grandparents, aunts, uncles ‐‐
'cause it gives lasting memories
every Christmas.
Get a seashell!
This year has been
really challenging
for me and my family.
My husband and I
are recently divorced,
so this is my first year
as a single mom.
Now being the only financial
provider of my household,
I have to make
this business work
so I can be a full‐time mom
and a full‐time entrepreneur
at the same time.
A deal from the Sharks
would definitely
make it the best Christmas ever.
♪♪
Hi, my name is Sarah Blain,
and I'm from Delray Beach,
Florida.
I'm asking for $150,000 for 20%
equity in my company.
I have one of the coolest jobs
out there.
I work for...
Santa Claus.
[ Laughter ]
You're probably wondering ‐‐
how does Santa respond
to all those letters
he receives each year?
Well, I'm about to let you in
on one of the North Pole's
best kept secrets ‐‐
Sealed by Santa.
Myself,
along with my elf friends,
help Santa reply
to all those letters.
Each letter is personalized,
comes with magical
reindeer food,
comes with a red wax seal,
and if that's not all,
it also comes directly
from the North Pole.
And that's not all.
It also comes with a phone call
from Santa
and two video messages.
Let's see if the
big guy's available
for a video chat right now.
Yeah.
[ Static ]
Ho, ho, ho, ho.
Hey, Santa.
Oh, hello, Sarah.
It's good to hear
from my favorite elf.
Are these the Sharks
you were telling me about?
They sure are.
I was wondering if it's okay
if I gave them the letters
that you sent.
Well, I've already
checked my list,
but I'll check it twice.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, let's see.
Robert.
Hi, Santa!
Lori.
[ Laughs ]
Hello.
‐Barbara.
I knew that was gonna happen.
And Mark.
They are all on my nice list.
I think it looks good, Sarah.
‐Yes!
Great!
‐Oh.
‐What about Kevin?
Wait a second.
I don't see Kevin on here.
‐Oh.
‐Aw.
Kevin, make sure to be nice
to my favorite elf
so you make my nice list, too.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Thanks, Santa.
Hey, listen, bozo,
I'm litigating.
[ Laughter ]
‐Ho, ho, ho, ho.
‐Uh‐oh, Kevin,
I really hope you're on
your best behavior
so I can go back
to the North Pole
and give Santa
a good report.
So, who wants to be a part
of Santa's official team
and invest in
Sealed by Santa?
But first,
let me get your letters.
Ah. It's okay, Kevin,
don't feel bad.
I think we're gonna be able
to turn that around, Kevin.
I think we all saw that one
coming, right?
‐Thank you, Sarah.
‐There's one. Thank you.
‐Lori, right from Santa.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
Shocking how they can fit coal
in one of those envelopes.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Look at my Nice list.
This is the envelope
you're mailing?
Yes.
Oh, Rudolph signed it,
too, Sarah.
Yes, he does.
So as you can see,
each letter is personalized
to you.
So what happens is, um,
a mother, father, grandmother,
aunt, best friend,
they'll go on our site,
and they'll tell us
about their child.
So there's accomplishments
on the letter,
wish list items,
of course, their name,
a customized P. S.,
so once we get that letter,
we get it printed out,
we put a red wax seal on it,
reindeer food, and it does ship
straight to the North Pole
to get approved by Santa
and postmarks back.
‐It's so cute.
‐Thank you.
"I see that you're hoping
for a new race car,
a pair of dancing shoes,
and maybe a pair
of swimming trunks
for your next vacation
with Kym.
Those sound like great gifts."
So cute.
Let's walk through
the business model.
‐Okay.
‐You're an online site.
Correct.
So what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go
onto the site,
and you're gonna pick
from 12 different letters.
So we offer, um,
Baby's First Christmas.
We offer teen letters.
We offer a Christian letter.
What does it cost you
to acquire a customer?
It cost me about $1.50.
And what's the customer worth?
Um, well, each letter
I sell for ‐‐
a letter I sell for $10.95.
And it cost me
$1.25 to make,
and they go up to
different packages.
This is another really cool
thing about my business ‐‐
I get that letter out
in 24 hours.
Oh, you do now 'cause you only
get a few thousand.
What happens if it blows up
and you get 100,000?
I'm happy you asked that.
Last year, I got 45,000.
‐Oh, wow.
‐And we did great.
‐Wow.
So you did them all yourself?
Or you have little elves?
I have 12 elf friends that help
me during season.
What do they cost?
Um, last year, I spent $10,000
in, um, employment.
When did you start it, Sarah?
So I started this
10 years ago.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, 10 years.
But, um, I started it as
a hobby, and I had my kids.
I have a beautiful 6‐
and 3‐year‐old little girl.
I call this a business
in the last five years.
What are your sales?
My sales last year
were $355,000.
‐You did $355,000 last year?
‐Correct.
With a net of $180,000.
And what ‐‐ what did you do
the year before?
Before that,
we did $250,000.
‐So great growth.
‐When you grow the brand ‐‐
So there ‐‐ so really,
they're ‐‐
Sealed by Santa can only
play out once a year.
You know what?
I'm happy you asked that
'cause I'm gonna show you
something else.
So in the last year ‐‐
‐Where'd she go?
We did is we started going
to other businesses.
So this is
our summer letter.
So what we do is Santa
actually goes on vacation
to south Florida ‐‐
great for him.
And he puts in the letter
what the child needs
to work on to stay
on the Nice list.
So then, that took off.
So we started partying
with the Easter Bunny.
‐Cute.
‐How well is that selling?
Is that doing well now?
‐This is our first year
we did it, and we did about
$15,000 for each one.
So what ‐‐ so what I'm really
trying to do is
make this seasonal business
not seasonal anymore.
Do you have a database
of customers?
‐I do. Yes.
‐How many?
60,000.
‐60,000?
‐Yes.
Are you capturing the birth date
of the child?
Please tell me you are.
‐I am not at this time.
Shame on you.
You know, I feel like
I've, I've done a lot
and I know what I'm doing,
but there's things that I need
to grow on.
One is going to
different holidays.
Two, I do think there's
something retail here.
Retail?
Especially with
our evidence kits.
‐Oh.
‐Why would you want
to go retail?
How would you see yourself
as doing this retail?
The holy grail
for every entrepreneur.
I have ‐‐ I have an offer
for you, okay?
It fits into several
of my businesses
that should be
of interest to you.
Yes.
I have a massive
online business
for kids and their birthdays
and their holidays.
So this would fit into it,
but I can put you
onto what we call
the "Something Wonderful"
platform
where we all push
our names to each other,
and we make 15% discounts
to each other's bases.
And everybody does it because
the economics of driving down
customer acquisition
costs work.
I'll give you the $150,000
over 33 1/3%.
'Cause I add a lot of value.
You know, a wise man once said,
Mr. O'Leary,
"If you want to get ‐‐
‐Nobody calls me that.
Call me Mr. Wonderful,
my real name.
"If you want to get
something done,
give it to a single mom."
You're not gonna find somebody
with more drive
and, uh
[whispers indistinctly]
[ Cries ]
‐It's okay.
The offer's so good
you're crying?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Sarah has one offer
on the table from Kevin
for her letters‐from‐Santa
business Sealed by Santa.
But he wants a third
of her company.
The offer's so good
you're crying?
[ Crying ] Yeah.
No, you know what?
Well, then take it.
Forget these guys.
I would, but,
unfortunately,
I am the sole winner
of my family [sniffles]
and I know
what I have to make.
So I really want to stick
as close to that $25,000
of that 25% as possible.
But don't you think
I can quadruple or ‐‐
‐I do, but ‐‐
‐Grow your business by 10 times?
I also know what I have to do
for my girls.
So, I'm gonna
think about it.
I want to hear the other ones,
but I think that ‐‐
Sure.
We get close to that 25%
because ‐‐
I'll give you a minute to dry
up, and then I'll start talking.
Sorry.
It's been a crazy three months,
you know?
The day my husband left
was the day
I got the call
from "Shark Tank."
Kind of crazy.
But, um, maybe it was actually
the best day of my life
if you think
about it that way.
So it's
a little bit emotional
for those couple
months, but ‐‐
You know,
you remind me very much
of another business
and another single mom.
I'm talking about Trina
from Hoppy Paws,
and she came in here pitching
reindeer footprints.
‐Oh.
‐That you can put...
‐I remember that.
‐... up the sidewalk,
into your living room
so you can actually see
that Santa Claus
came down the chimney.
She had the magic elf,
then she had
the Easter Bunny prints ‐‐
It went on and on and on.
But in the end,
you know what sold?
The reindeer prints.
So I question you about the
other things you're trying
because, generally, seasonal
businesses are exactly that.
I think you have
a wonderful business.
I don't see it as a business
that has room for an investor.
And that's a problem,
so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Herjavec: Sarah,
you said to Kevin's offer
that you have to make a certain
amount of money out of it.
How much money do you need
to pull out
of the business every year?
I mean, I'd take
a $60,000 revenue now,
but, um...
to be at that $100,000 is
kind of where I need to be.
‐Got it.
‐And ‐‐
Well, you can just ask
for a salary.
Kevin, as part of this deal,
to give that equity,
I need a $100,000 salary.
Why won't you
just do that?
I might have to do that.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Let me explain
how this works.
Let's assume you accept my deal
of 33 1/3%.
‐Okay.
‐And I put $150,000 capital in.
I don't want to tell you
what to do with it.
I expect you to put it to work
in the best way possible.
‐Right.
‐But we're partners.
As you withdraw capital,
I get 33 1/3%
and you get the rest.
‐Right.
‐That's how it works.
What you've done, you know,
you should be proud of yourself.
‐Thank you.
‐That's a major accomplishment.
You know,
I see a couple red flags.
I really think you're trying
to do too much
by going to the different
holidays.
I think when you talk about
wanting to go into retail,
that shows a lack of focus.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, thank you so much.
Herjavec:
Sarah, I like it.
I mean, I ‐‐ I get your need
for a salary,
so, you know, Kevin said
you get 2/3, he gets 1/3.
I don't need that. I have a job
that already pays me money.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So I'll give you
the $150,000 for 1/3 ‐‐
33 1/3%.
You get to make $100,000.
We split the profit
above that.
So the first $100,000
goes to you,
and we invest the money
into growing the business.
I do think you can expand it
into other seasons.
But you got to go to the other
holidays right away.
I agree.
And, you know what?
I think we're gonna try to
partner with the Tooth Fairy.
I think there's
a big market there.
That's really interesting.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you
a $75,000 loan
and $75,000
I'll put into the company.
I'll do it of 22 1/2%.
‐Yo.
And if we do well in retail,
I'm happy to continue to fund
the inventory
that we would need to get in.
Okay.
This is a lot to think about.
[ Laughs ]
Congratulations,
you have three offers.
Now you have to decide.
‐I know.
Um...
Ugh, oh, man,
this is so hard.
‐Lori ‐‐
‐What'd you decide?
‐You have a deal.
‐Yay. Good.
‐Thank you.
‐I loved it.
And I love
the Tooth Fairy thing.
[ Laughs ]
I think that's so genius.
Thank you so much.
Bye!
‐Congrats, Sarah.
Whew. Okay.
That was crazy.
I couldn't give up 33%
of my company.
I needed this for my kids,
and the deal that Lori made me
was a perfect deal
for my situation.
I was born and raised in
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
My grandparents came over
from Russia.
Their name was Chabinsky.
And when they got
to Ellis Island,
they were like, "Nah."
Chop, chop, chop.
And it ended up being Cuban.
I grew up in
a working‐class family.
My dad did upholstery on cars.
My mom did every type
of job imaginable.
People thought I might
go work at a mill.
My mom wanted me to learn
how to lay carpet
because she was concerned
about my future.
Nobody had high hopes for me,
but I was a hustler.
I've always been selling.
From reselling baseball cards
to stamps and coins,
[ Chuckling ] I always had
something going on.
That was just my nature.
Since college,
I've been a tech geek.
I had quit or been fired
from three straight jobs.
So I figured it was time
to start my own company.
And so I started MicroSolutions.
Back then, I'd take my floppy,
I walked over
to the other computer.
That's how we shared.
But I was like, "No,
it's all gonna be different
in the future."
So we started learning how to
connect our computers together.
In 1995, streaming didn't exist.
My partner and I had this idea
for being able
to listen to sports over this
new thing called the Internet.
From there, we started
broadcast. com.
We just saw this as
a unique opportunity
to combine sports with
the leading organization
on the Internet.
In April 2000,
we closed our deal with Yahoo!
for $5.7 billion
in Yahoo! stock.
Come on, Joey,
get your crew together!
I paid $285 million
for the Mavs.
Everybody said you're an idiot
because the Mavs suck
and that was the largest price
ever paid for any
sports team ever.
I was like, "I don't care."
I got to go party with
the entire city of Dallas.
It was just a dream come true.
Since then, we've never
had a losing record.
Been to the conference finals
three times,
been to the finals twice,
and finally won the NBA
championship in 2011.
This is where I grew up.
This is where I played
basketball,
where I traded baseball cards.
It's where I'd ride my bike down
and wipe out,
try to ride my bike back up
and barely make it.
I mean, this is home.
Today's my first time back
at Mount Lebanon High School
since I graduated.
Man: I'm really proud to
introduce Mount Lebanon's own
class of 1976, Mr. Mark Cuban.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cuban: I care a lot about
influencing kids
because I have three young kids.
I care about the world
they're gonna live in.
Who here has had
a business idea?
[ Laughter ]
I love entrepreneurship
because that's what makes
this country grow.
And if I can help companies
grow, I'm creating jobs,
I'm setting foundation
for future generations.
It sends the message
that the American dream
is alive and well.
I want you all to think,
"Who's next?"
And what are you guys gonna do
to get there?
Try different things because
there's absolutely nothing
that can possibly stop you guys.
Whatever your goals are,
if I can give you confidence
and give you encouragement
when you watch "Shark Tank,"
I've accomplished a lot.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a way
to bring home
a favorite winter activity.
♪♪
Herjavec: Aw.
Hi, Sharks, my name
is Jim Loughran.
I'm seeking $150,000 for 20%
equity in my business.
I'm here today
to bring the rink home.
And PolyGlide Synthetic Ice
makes it simple.
There's no need
for refrigeration,
and best of all,
you don't even need ice.
Let me show you how it works.
Simply click and lock
the ice panels together,
and you convert any playroom,
garage, or outdoor patio
into your own home rink
in a matter of minutes.
‐That is cool.
‐So, if you want to practice
at home to be the next great one
in hockey.
[ Whistle blows ]
Ooh!
Fight, fight!
[ Chatter ]
Or become the next
Olympic gold medalist.
[ Light laughter ]
PolyGlide brings it all home.
So what Shark would like to
invest in a product
that's guaranteed to score?
Where do people
really use this?
You'd be surprised
how many people
convert their garage space
into a rink,
and they can skate
in their garage.
But that's great until I see
that hockey puck
flying in the air
and breaking something
like a window or something.
But not everybody uses it
for hockey.
What do people use it for,
Jim?
Figure skating, typically,
they like to ‐‐
the skaters, they just want to
just skate and train at home.
Mm‐hmm.
And without going back
and forth to the rink.
They can set up their own garage
rink and practice right at home.
‐This is ‐‐
‐I have seen this product.
So what's the difference between
your product and the other ones?
Loughran:
Here's what they don't have.
They don't have the scaled‐down,
mini panels, which no one sells.
‐The what?
‐Small portions.
They're only commercial size,
and you're residential?
Correct.
Or you've just chosen to sell
in smaller configurations.
I changed the size and
the design of the product.
And I infused the plastic
with a lubricant.
This concept was tried
in hockey arenas.
You can't classify it
as strictly a hockey product.
Well, whatever it is
'cause there's a certain feel
when you're on
the ice, right?
‐Sure.
‐So, is there a difference?
Yeah, that's one of the reasons
why I designed
this particular product
with the infuse of lubricants
to make it less restriction.
‐Is yours 10%?
‐Can I just see it?
Yes, I have some samples
here, also.
‐Can you pass them out?
‐Sure.
‐Thank you.
‐Whoa.
‐Whoa, careful.
‐Careful.
There you go.
Do a spin.
I have some skates here
for anybody that wants to ‐‐
‐Yeah, can I try?
‐Like to give it a try?
‐Yeah.
‐What size are you?
‐Uh, nine.
‐Just look in the kids' section.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect. I'll go over there
and put them on.
Greiner: Do you have to wear
any special skate?
Or it's regular skates?
‐No, they're normal skates.
‐Yeah.
‐This is the infused,
and this is the dry.
‐Oh, okay.
‐Infused, dry.
‐Yours and competition?
Correct.
Yours feels, to me,
more like smooth ice,
whereas this feels...
‐Careful, not so fast!
‐... artificial.
Corcoran: Oh!
[ Laughs ]
‐Wow.
‐Awesome, Robert.
‐Wow, nicely done. Bravo.
‐Good job, Robert.
What are your sales?
Uh, total sales since I started,
$1.3 million.
Wow.
That's lifetime
for the 3 1/2 years.
And this year, I'm on pace
to break $400,000.
Jim, what does it cost?
What does that size cost?
‐$69.95.
‐For one square?
For the cost of one panel.
If I was buying your panels
in that format,
how many would I need
to make this? Take a guess.
You would probably need
three racks of the 24.
So I would take 60 times $70,
that would give me
the cost of this.
Correct.
So the cost of this would be
$4,200, for this display.
Tennis court is
the standard configuration
that everybody
understands.
‐30x60 is $8 a square foot.
‐So about $15,000.
‐Jim, you don't know the answer?
‐Is that $15,000?
I call you up,
I have a tennis court,
I want to turn it
into a rink.
What does it cost me?
15 grand, give or take.
I need Mark Cuban
on the phone
with me to figure that out?
Everybody needs
a Mark Cuban.
Most people don't want
that large of a rink
just to skate at home.
‐Well ‐‐
‐They need maybe ‐‐
‐But don't you ‐‐
‐100 square feet.
Jim, who sells most
of these for you?
I sell them all myself.
‐So you're direct‐to‐consumer?
‐Is it online?
I do everything, yeah.
Jim, how many competitors
do you have you have online?
There's about
six other competitors
that are doing something similar
that I'm doing online.
And where do you rank?
Do you have a sense of are you
at the top of that heap?
Yeah, obviously,
I'm in the top six.
Wait, there's six competitors,
and you're in the top six?
That's the
best answer ever.
Where do you rank?
You know, not one, not two ‐‐
I'm in the top six.
I never try to say I'm better
than anybody else.
Well, you should.
‐But I'm telling you this ‐‐
‐But you have to ‐‐
I'm as good as,
as anybody else out there.
Come on, Jim,
up that energy.
‐Okay.
‐Jim, look,
millions of people
are going to see this.
You can't be
half‐ass about it.
This is your show.
‐Sure.
‐Right?
This has got to be
the most important
thing in the world
to you.
You got to
sell it that way.
So why are you better
than anybody else? Tell us.
Because the product that
I developed is infused
and gives
the best performance.
‐How good is it?
‐And what's it infused with?
It's ‐‐ That is proprietary,
and that I cannot ‐‐
Yeah. So, Jim, we shouldn't
have to pull teeth
to get you to do
these things, right?
It shouldn't be,
"I'm going to do."
It should be,
"I have done."
You got to be aggressive
in order to be able to repay
an investor money
and make us all a lot
of money, right?
And I don't get that sense.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
No retailer's gonna bring 1,000
pounds of PolyGlide slabs,
'cause it takes up
too much space
and it's very hard
for the consumer
to take home enough
to make a rink.
It's a good business for you,
but I don't see it scaling
as a product ‐‐
particularly in retail ‐‐
that's a really bad idea.
I'm out.
I respect that.
Thank you.
It's a clever idea,
but I like to invest in things
where I know it's gonna
hit a lot of people,
has appeal to many,
and so, for that reason ‐‐
because this doesn't ‐‐
I'm out.
I appreciate it, Lori,
thank you.
You played hockey yourself,
did you?
Yes.
I think you got to change
your game here,
big time, and it's inside.
When I was first selling
real estate, everyone loved me,
everyone enjoyed
spending time with me,
and then they bought
from the next guy.
Until I realized
I had to show energy.
And the minute I reached
into myself
and started getting
really excitable
about the same product that
everybody else in town sold,
I started selling better
than everybody.
So, I wish you had come here
with your hockey helmet on,
your hockey attitude, and was
just like, "Let me go get it.
Let me go get it."
'Cause I think you would have
had all sharks in on you.
But for the lack of energy,
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Pleasure.
And then there's one.
♪♪
Yeah, I ‐‐ I ‐‐
I love the product.
It felt really good.
You've got a great business.
But what you're really
gonna need is,
you're gonna need sales help.
I mean, I think ‐‐ as everybody
here's said that to you.
I think you're gonna need a lot
of help, and you're one of six.
I don't see
the wide scale of it.
I'm out.
I respect that.
Thank you.
‐Pleasure.
‐Good luck, Jim.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you.
If I had a second chance
to get back in there,
obviously I would light
the place up.
If they think otherwise,
then I can't change that,
but I can tell you this ‐‐
when it comes to selling
the product,
I am aggressive
and I make it happen.
Narrator: Next in the tank
is a business
that makes gift giving
even more personal.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Brad Bosvovic.
And I'm Charlie Williams, and
our company is Digiwrap, Inc.
We're seeking $150,000
for 10% of our company.
Digiwrap is the only company
in the world
taking gift bags
and tissue paper
to where it's never
been before.
Everyone does
the same thing ‐‐
you take a boring, generic bag,
like that.
You wrap your gift in a plain
piece of tissue paper
that you put no thought into,
you stuff it in the bag,
and you're done, right?
Wrong!
In a world that's gone
completely digital
and personalized in almost
every imaginable way,
isn't it about time our gift
packaging has caught up?
Well, now it has,
thanks to us.
Because we can turn that ‐‐
Into this.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Herjavec: Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Our digital processes
allow us
to make these products
when no one else can.
And they can be made
as one‐offs,
and we can customize
them on demand.
With the other guys,
you'll have to wait weeks
for your product.
But not with Digiwrap.
We can do as many or as few
as you'd like
in a matter of days,
rather than weeks,
and it's all done right here
in the good old U. S. of A.
Digiwrap is about making
gift packaging personal.
So, what do you say,
Sharks?
Should we go ahead
and get a deal wrapped up?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Very cute.
We have some gifts
for you guys.
Now, we did customize
each of these for you.
‐Thank you.
‐So take a look,
there's a good amount
of detail there.
‐Thank you.
‐It's very nice pictures,
nice quality.
‐Can't I do this today?
You know,
at our corporate events,
we give out bags with our logo
and a picture.
It is possible to get large runs
of bags like this.
No one, currently, is doing
short‐run photo bags.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You could do small runs
with unique printing.
There's at least five different
platforms to do that on.
When we say a small run
we mean one‐offs.
This is one bag.
‐One?
‐One bag.
Corcoran: Why would someone
order one bag?
So, if I want to give you
a present, Barb,
that's customized to you.
‐Absolutely. And, in fact ‐‐
‐And what would ‐‐
what would Mark pay
for that bag?
So, they typically retail
for as much as $10.
Your advantage is, you can do it
on very small runs,
as small as one.
'Cause, digitally, I can do this
on a larger scale.
Well, for the bags, yes.
I want to point out
that we do have
customer tissue paper in there,
too, and that is unique.
We currently have two lines
of business, right?
So, we have our own online site
where we focus, currently,
on just the tissue paper.
But we also have
a partnership
with a large, online,
personalized retailer,
and we sell
to them wholesale.
‐Who?
‐Zazzle.
Okay. So,
I go to the website,
yours or Zazzle's,
upload my picture.
What do you do with it and what
about that process is unique?
We are able to use our patent
for our tissue paper.
Wait a second.
You can't tell me
you're the only guys who can
make this wrapping paper.
‐Currently, we are.
‐No way.
‐Yeah.
‐I don't buy that for a second.
If you wanted custom,
digital for tissue paper,
there in no one else.
So, then, how many millions
of dollars of sales
are you doing
with custom tissue paper?
We've only been in business
for two years,
and, last year,
we sold $350,000.
And, this year,
we're on track for $500,000.
‐For tissue paper?
‐For tissue and bags.
Digiwrap takes cutting‐edge
printing technology
that's used in scale out
there ‐‐ millions of sheets ‐‐
and makes it viable for a single
order for a consumer?
Is that really what's going on?
That's a very succinct
description of it, yes.
Okay, now that we've distilled
what the deal is ‐‐
it's making this tissue paper ‐‐
what does it cost you to make it
and how much
do you sell it for?
It costs us an average of
about 50 cents to make it,
we sell it for an average
of about $1.
The value of your company,
if you're just a supplier
to a single customer,
is not that exciting.
Herjavec: Charlie,
where is the break point
to where a business can go
to a competitor?
You're almost living on the
fringe of the printing business.
And it's a really unique
problem you have
because, if you get
a customer,
and the customer becomes
too big,
they're not good for you.
You got to go find another one.
I think it works on sites
where this is part of something
else, like a Zazzle.
But for you to build
your own company
and acquire those customers,
I think it's gonna be
really tough.
It's a beautiful product,
but I don't see it going large.
I'm out.
Cuban:
Robert's point is right on.
It's gonna take so many deals
to get to a size
that really makes it
worthwhile to invest.
The challenge,
as an investor ‐‐
I'd have to see a real
return because,
if I give you $150,000 for 10%
and you grow five times ‐‐
all right, I mean,
it's nice
and you guys have grown
your business,
but I haven't moved
the needle for myself.
I'm out.
‐Okay, thank you.
Thank you
for considering it.
Corcoran: I don't believe
there's enough of a market
for customized tissue paper,
enough to warrant having
a partner in your business.
I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara,
we appreciate it.
Greiner:
Printing has come a long way.
This is really
excellent‐looking.
I see the promotion
and the keepsake part,
but I think people also don't
like to spend a whole lot
on packaging because
people throw it away.
I'm out.
Well, thank you
for your time, Lori.
O'Leary: It's a unique niche,
I get what you're doing,
but I don't know how
to blow this up.
I mean,
the biggest thing is,
we've proved that the product
is wanted and is coveted.
And every day,
someone else finds us,
someone else
spreads the word.
Listen, here's an offer ‐‐
$150,000,
we're partners, 50/50.
Huh.
I'm sorry,
it's a little steep, Kevin.
A little?
You think?
‐Can we ‐‐ can we ‐‐
‐It's downright greedy.
‐Yes.
‐No, it isn't.
It's a small, niche,
crazy‐chicken deal.
I want 50%.
That's the only deal, and if
you don't want it, I'm okay.
You know, we could meet you
in the middle somewhere.
We're very eager and ‐‐
What's "meet me
in the middle"?
You know,
we'd be comfortable
with something in
the ballpark of maybe 20%.
That's not the middle.
It's not the middle.
Cuban: But it's close.
It's middle‐ish.
"Middle‐ish" [ Laughs ]
Okay, listen,
I'll do it for ‐‐
I'll do it for 40%.
I'm willing to come down.
That's very generous.
That's a huge discount.
Unfortunately, we can't go up
to 40%, for sure.
‐What can you go to?
‐25%?
No. It's ‐‐ do you know
what the deal is?
It's 35% or not.
You've got to understand that
we see this as a lot bigger
than what it sounds like
you guys have understood it to.
So, we probably made
a mistake there.
We know you like
royalty deals.
‐Did I hear "royalty"?
‐You did.
You did.
‐What's the deal?
We'll give you equity
and a royalty deal.
How much equity?
15%.
And what's the royalty?
Every sheet of tissue paper
we sell,
we'll give you a nickel,
and every bag we sell,
we'll give you 40 cents.
‐Ooh.
‐That's a rich royalty.
You sure you want to do that?
‐A nickel. Whoa.
And that's just until you get
your money back, though.
That's just until
you get your money back.
Oh, wait a minute.
Meanwhile, you've still got
your equity, though. Right?
So, you still got
your equity.
Okay, here's the deal.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 20% equity,
but I want a nickel
on every tissue
and a dime on every bag
in perpetuity.
You're literally
nickel‐and‐diming them.
Absolutely.
Perpetuity ‐‐
we couldn't do perpetuity ‐‐
we couldn't give you equity
and perpetuity.
We can meet in
the middle somewhere ‐‐
Okay, here's the deal.
I'll do this.
The royalty goes away
at $450,000, all right?
Gone.
I get three times on my dough,
and I'm still your partners
at 20%
and we're still in
the tissue business.
I mean, it's so crazy.
I'm not worried about
competition ‐‐
no one else is gonna go
after this market,
I can tell you that.
‐Right.
‐Take it or leave it.
Yes or no?
Yes.
Yeah, absolutely.
‐Hallelujah!
‐I'm in the tissue business!
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you, Kevin.
You're gonna get that money way
faster than you would think.
‐All right, thanks a lot.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, everyone.
‐Caio, guys.
Congrats, guys.
Cuban: Congrats.
Whew.
That was brutal.
Well, we did it.
Yes, we did it.
‐It is pretty.
‐Yeah.
‐I do love my bag.
‐It's a nice bag.
‐I like the bag.
‐Uh, a nickel, please.
Narrator: Next into the tank is
a more functional version
of a common winter accessory.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Don Wildman,
I live in Malibu, California,
and I'm co‐founder
of Hand Out Gloves.
And I'm Jake Sullivan
from Salt Lake City, Utah,
co‐founder and president
of Hand Out Gloves.
We're seeking $150,000
equity investment
plus a $150,000 loan for 20%
ownership in our company.
‐Oh, that's interesting.
‐Interesting.
I've been in the business world
for over 50 years.
I've created, started, and
managed successful businesses ‐‐
one doing annual sales of over
$1 billion a year ‐‐
and I feel that this new product
we have, Hand Out Gloves,
will revolutionize and dominate
the $8 billion glove market.
We found that our gloves are
always getting in the way.
You have to take them off,
find somewhere to put them,
and when it comes time to put
them back on, it's a nightmare,
especially if snow
finds its way inside.
So, Hand Out Gloves
was born.
All it took was a strategically
placed, waterproof zipper,
and now you don't have
to take you gloves off
to check your phone,
crack a beer.
Quickly gain full
five‐finger dexterity
for whatever it is
you need to do,
or simply dump
excess heat.
♪♪
‐What's this?
‐Cool.
Oh, wow.
That's how you dump
excess heat?
Yeah.
Greiner: Wow.
Herjavec: Very cool.
Now, everything you couldn't do
with your gloves on
is now possible,
and you don't have to take them
off to do it.
Just zip,
and your hand is out.
‐Impressive.
‐Dang.
And so, we really need,
particularly at 85 ‐‐
84 years old,
I don't want to go
ahead of 85 ‐‐
I need all the help
I can get.
Jake's the young man,
so we're looking for some guys
that have some brainpower
that we can add to our team.
And, hopefully, you'll have
the same kind of enthusiasm
we have to dominate
the glove industry.
Now, let me pass out
some samples
for you guys to see,
yourselves.
‐Yeah.
‐Please.
Thanks, Jake.
There you go, Lori.
‐Thank you.
‐Here you are, Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you, Jake.
Barbara.
‐Oh, mittens.
‐Thanks, Jake.
Appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
So, Don, I got to tell you,
you are one ripped dude.
Holy crap.
‐Wow.
Are you really 85?
I'll be 84 in February.
I sort of hedged a little bit.
‐Son of a gun.
‐You are in amazing shape.
You're gonna be
my third husband.
[ Laughter ]
He's way too young for you,
Barbara.
Fifth wife.
I love all kinds of sports.
I've done the IRONMAN
nine times.
Herjavec: You've done
the IRONMAN nine times?
He won it once.
What company did you run
that got to over
a billion dollars?
A Bally's Fitness.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, really?
It was
a health‐club chain.
We had 450 clubs at the end
of my reign.
Oh, yeah.
Huge company.
I'm gonna assume
you're a millionaire.
I'm worth about
$100 million, yeah.
I'm a big skier,
and I've got kids.
I used to buy them gloves
that had the mitt inside
and you could take the ‐‐
like yours, you could take
the finger part off.
‐Fingers out.
‐Yeah.
And you could keep
your fingers out.
So, what sets us apart is the
full five‐finger dexterity,
allowing your thumbs
to come out.
Do you have a patent
on the product?
We currently have a pending
utility patent
that was filed in February.
Well, tell us about
your sales.
I bet people are receiving
you well.
Talk about the company
and the economics.
So, first‐year sales
was $15,000.
And that was pretty much
regionally in Salt Lake City.
And this year,
we're at $125,000 so far.
‐Good for you.
‐Okay, so what happened
between $10,000
to $125,000?
We got picked up
by Big box.
‐Which one?
‐REI.
That's the only retailer
you're in now?
Besides our 12
core shops locally.
Like, little ski shops.
How about online?
Anything online?
We're on Amazon,
and then we have our direct
sales from our site.
‐How much do you sell it for?
‐How much does it cost,
and how much
do you make it for?
So, depending on the style ‐‐
anywhere from the one Lori has
is our lightweight ‐‐
those cost $11,
wholesale for $20,
and they retail for $40.
‐What about this?
‐That's our Pro model.
That one costs $32,
we wholesale it for $60,
and it retails $120.
It's a great glove.
Like, it's really well‐made.
It's a durable glove, and
the ones I'm actually wearing
is the only pair I've had the
entire length of the company.
‐Four years.
So, you were saying
you have a patent pending.
‐Correct.
‐What's the patent on?
Just unzipping it?
So, it's on the zipper and then,
also, the wrist strap.
So, you get your hand out,
and the way
the wrist strap functions ‐‐
if your hand's gonna be out
for a long duration ‐‐
it tucks it
out of the way.
So, Jake, you're out there,
you guys are hustling,
you've got
a Big box retailer.
What's the game plan for
the next couple of years?
Honestly, we'd like to expand
into other markets.
We started with skiing
and snowboarding,
but we see it functioning
for everyone else ‐‐
hunting, fishing,
construction, military.
But it is a seasonal product.
We do have the option
of the southern hemisphere,
which has the complete
opposite winter.
So, this is something
we could run year‐round.
How did you two meet?
I've been skiing up in Utah
for the last 3‐some years.
And I'm 28,
he's known me my whole life.
His mother sold me
a place up there.
He worked for a glove
manufacturer,
and he built the company.
‐That's my history.
‐And then they sort of...
‐Got it.
‐Now you're the glove guy.
‐Now I'm the glove guy.
‐So, he says to you,
"Hey, I've got this idea"?
The deal came up,
I said, "Jake,
this might be a great
opportunity for you."
‐He's the guy.
‐Yeah, he is the guy.
Don, tell us a little bit
about your background.
You're in amazing shape,
you started Bally's.
I'm a typical guy.
I can identify with him
'cause I didn't graduate
from high school.
I started Bally's after
I got out of the army.
I was a combat medic
in Korea.
Wow.
I went to work for
a small health‐club chain,
and then they went bankrupt
and the creditors came to me
and said,
"You get our money back,
we'll give you the clubs."
So, I took five clubs over
in Chicago
and then built it into a deal
where, ultimately,
I got bought out
and it allowed me
to go snowboard
70, 80 days a year.
Cuban:
They're great gloves.
Why do you think
you haven't sold more?
Because we
haven't really ‐‐
we've been concentrating
in the Utah market, basically.
It's been really regional,
right now, in the West.
I think you're missing
a piece here.
I think you have Don,
who I think, Don,
you're a good salesman.
‐You got to talk loud.
I said, "Don,
you're a handsome man!"
Well, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
If I had some better ears
it'd be better.
Okay. Don, I said you're
a natural‐born salesman,
I feel, so ‐‐ I'm sure you've
been selling your whole life.
Jake, I don't think you are.
But I'm gonna
make you an offer.
But I want somebody else
in with me,
'cause I'm not gonna take
this amount of risk.
I'm gonna give you half
the money you're looking for,
for 12.5% equity,
but you have to get another
shark to come in
for the other half,
for a total of 25% equity.
Herjavec:
Don, you're one impressive guy,
and I think that the challenge
is, it is a fantastic glove,
but there are
similar products.
I don't know how I can help it
get really big.
I'm out.
Cuban: I think it's a brilliant
glove, right?
I'll wear it, I'll tell people,
I'll show bit off, all right?
The challenge is putting
together a marketing plan
and having the organization
that you need.
I've always been ‐‐ you know,
I had 15,000 employees ‐‐
‐Wow.
‐And you get too large.
Oh, no, look,
I agree with you there.
The question is, if I come in,
what happens?
If I had people that were
in the outdoors market
that I really could just say,
"You know what,
let's just fit you in.
We'll complement the people
that you have."
This is just not one of the
areas I've ever focused on.
So, I'm out.
Corcoran:
Don, I offered you half of what
you were looking for here,
but you have to get
someone else in.
Now you only have Lori
and Mr. Wonderful.
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Barbara's willing to put up
half the money
Don and Jake are seeking
for a 12.5% stake
in their Hand Out Glove company.
But they must get the rest of
the money from another shark.
What do you think, guys?
I've gone through the process
of getting a product into a Big
box in winter garments and ‐‐
the word is, it sobered me.
It made me realize
how frigging hard it is,
and how the whole things skews
to big guys
that are willing to invest
huge amounts of capital.
It's not for me,
but the story's fantastic.
Sorry, guys, I'm out.
All right.
Thank you, Kevin.
‐All right, Kevin's out.
‐All right, Lori.
I think, for me,
you guys are great guys.
You're amazing.
‐Uh‐oh, doesn't sound good.
But the problem is,
it's such a crowded space,
it worries me to invest in it.
You were sharing your sales.
I think the reason
that the sales are small
is not because it's not good,
but just because
there's so many options.
No, that wasn't the case.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
‐The case was it was ‐‐
‐Thank you.
‐Barb.
‐Everybody's out.
‐Ay‐yi‐yi.
If you believe in it,
if you believe enough in it ‐‐
Barb, come in
for the full 25%.
Yeah.
Do you believe enough in it to
put up the entire $150,000?
I'll tell you
what I'll do.
If you believe in it, Barb,
do the deal.
‐My lover is speaking.
‐All right.
For 25%,
I'll take $300,000
and put it in as capital
into the company.
So, now the company has
a better balance sheet.
‐I'll tell you what, Don ‐‐
‐What?
I'll give you ‐‐ if you want to
put your $300,000 in as capital,
I'll give you another $300,00
as a credit line
against cost of goods,
with 6% interest,
for 25% equity.
So, just so I'm clear ‐‐
Don's got to put
in $300,000
to the company in terms
of equity.
‐The current ‐‐
‐Yeah.
You'll put up $300,000
as a line of credit
against receivables.
But you want 25%.
Yes, Robert.
Barbara, we'd love
to take that deal.
‐Yes!
‐Good job, guys.
‐Whoo!
‐Well done.
‐Easy, Don, easy.
‐Don, I'm so happy to hear it.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐Whoa!
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Lovely.
Herjavec: Keep your hands
off him, Barb!
‐I can't help myself.
‐Good job.
‐Keep working out.
‐Wow, look at your arms.
A few years
to look like you.
‐That was fun.
‐That was awesome, Wildman.
I think we got
the good deal.
Wildman:
We do feel proud of ourselves,
being able to tell people
that the Shark Tank
had enough faith in this
business to jump in.
It means a lot, and it gives us
even more confidence
than we already had.